all right sitting here right here
actually with my two nephews right here
a couple young buckaroos and uh
tell me about yourself let's start with
you brother my name
is max and i'm eight years old and
i'm taking an eight-hour road trip from
louisiana
okay and what brought you here to uh to
this area what brought you out here to
the central east brother
you looking for work or what no my
parents said that um we were gonna go
because it's
a summer break and um
we have nothing else to do at home okay
and this fellow over here and how do you
know him this other guy oh
he's my brother okay are you guys
friends also would you say max or what
do you feel like
no okay we can be friends but we can be
mortal enemies as well
mostly mortal enemies though all right
and your name bud
my name is zephy i am
nine years old and
um you looking for love
not not yet okay he stopped for like
three okay
that's fine man i've been there dude
i've definitely had times where i was
looking for love and times where i
wasn't
did you marry morgan wallin i wouldn't
marry i mean i don't think
both of us prefer women yeah so
but i kind of get that i think if there
were
if it were a different if we lived in a
different universe there could be a
chance
i don't know i don't know if he how are
you i don't know how he can communicate
with each other if you lived in a
different universe
i don't know it's a great question man
it is a great question
if we live in a different universe i
don't know i guess we would probably it
was a great question i think you would
probably
because you have to create a way to get
there
like a shuttle ship or like a space
travel or you could just dream of
killing city war they went
it was either an infinity war or in-game
they
went and they ship with the guardians of
the galaxy move this closer to you
and they broke sue and they broke
through the space and it created like a
yeah you have to break through space
yeah i'm look i'm not doing that
yeah i got enough going on here i mean
and there's like space people could
do that because he's like albert
einstein i'm not doing it i'm saying i
just bought
flowers i'm not i'm doing stuff at the
house you bought a bunch of flowers why
does it say that truck
kind of fun because it was a 120 dollar
tree
what kind of flowers you got like three
of them sean likes to spend that money
what kind of flowers i'm not sure so let
me ask you a question guys
are you guys single men or what's
let's go one at a time here let's start
with you zephy are you single these days
or what's
what's uh love looking like in your life
have you started thinking about girls or
that kind of
or what what happens at nine years old i
like thinking about
food okay yeah me too but like
i'm not i'm not that much of a
of a person that will start a
conversation
i can sit and wait because i don't want
to be mean
to like and if somebody starts talking
to me
i just carry on and keep talking but
like
i usually don't like to engage in
conversations
okay so you're more like the you'll
you'll continue a conversation but you
won't start a conversation
yeah it's like if you're in a video game
you
land somewhere that is not contested but
you're not afraid to fight
right like that okay okay i got it
and max what about you were you the kind
of guy will start a conversation do you
even know
how to communicate what is going on with
you i really don't know how to talk to
girls
at all okay um and i like this one girl
in my class but i get bullied
you get bullied by her no i get bullied
by everyone because i like girl because
i like
a girl dang yeah did you let her know or
not
it's at school but like i think i think
i'm
done he he i think it's
what's everywhere what's every like
elementary school
crush you die you wait
till they they find out that they like
you
that you like them okay so how do you
let someone know say if
there is a crush right which is totally
normal i was boys you just
you you either ask your friend to do it
or you
write a note put it in your desk and
then leave school yeah yeah that's my
old move dude
okay so i have this really funny story
or leave town that's what i would do
leave town i have this really funny
story that started at like the beginning
of the school year and we're still we
were still laughing at it until the end
okay and this one
this kid my best friend who was my best
friend his name is um
randall no ocean okay he liked this girl
named clarice
stop it and they liked each other and
then we were like
and then um so we're still laughing at
it for like the entire
school year and are they still together
i don't think
they didn't find each other but they're
probably what do you mean find each
other
i mean they have they they are they real
people guys
um to be real i have no idea okay it's
probably like a virtual assistant that
he uses of course that's what i was
going to guess
now let's talk about some of you guys's
plans for the future i know you guys
right now
are you're nine years old you said zephy
and max i can start
you're six years old yeah yeah yeah yeah
so
okay i can start yeah i just want to
know some of your plans for the future
i want to be honest with you please i
want to be a foot doctor
oh really podiatrist they call it foot
man they call it
on the street wait a minute
what if the patient has foot fungus will
you eat it
look question will you eat the fun
[ __ ] guess or will you throw it away
do you know foot fungus tastes like goat
milk really i drink good bloating every
day for blue cheese tastes like goat
milk i know a friend that's addicted to
blue cheese
in my in my um inoculations
in my cereal um yeah this is not true
most of my friends
this isn't true in my cereal instead of
using milk i use goat milk with foot
fungus in it i'm addicted to caramel
really yeah i i take bottles he's
addicted to
caramel out of it okay so you want to be
a foot doctor
and zephy what do you when you think
about your future and where you are now
do you have any big plans do you have
any like what do you like what do you
kind of see yourself in the future a few
years down the road from now do you see
yourself kind of still living in the
same house do you see yourself having a
job
if it's a few years down
i'd probably
you gonna stay living with your parents
are you gonna no i want i'm gonna
move out when i have the money and stuff
okay and i want to move in to an
apartment
and get a job and a couple animals or
something or what
uh i want to get a
uh is it legal to have a bobcat as a pet
i bet it is oh um i want to get a bobcat
or like
i really want a a cockatoo or a parakeet
because you can talk to them
funny story actually my aunt
and my mother funny story actually
had a parrot a red parrot and he would
and he would say they would always say
like shut up
ricky and then and so and so um the
parent would always say
shut up ricky really and he would say
and the parent would say butthead
oh so the parrot is really he can he
kind of has a mind of his own huh
yeah but it's like an influence from
his owners he's an influencer yeah i
think so
the parrot is yeah they don't the
parents
not on tick tock but no no the parent
went viral like a few years later
oh dad he is friends he went viral on
he's friends with
um bryce hall he actually cut bryce
hall's
hair who did a parrot oh really yeah
good i could imagine that now let me ask
you guys my dad is lebron james
no he's not max how do you know that
this
let's talk about some some things you
guys are not good at i want you to each
share something
in my life what are you good at
like eating and sleeping okay and what
are you not good at
everything do you think you guys as
parents will stay together for a long
time have you guys talked about
that or what does their relationship
seem like uh yeah we joke around
sometimes say that they're cheating on
each other that's some reason
right max that's very
very you style but like at the same time
that's like a bad influence for your
children
i'm i don't have children but you're
like your children in the future
my child is um actually what are you
gonna name your children
i'm gonna name them uh
goober i'm gonna name them goofy
and goober oh wow are they gonna be
twins or female or male
they're gonna be attack helicopters oh
wow beautiful
i could see that actually seems very on
brand with where we're headed as a
society
yes what do you think zephy now when you
start to look at um
the world today do you think the world's
headed in a good direction what are some
of your thoughts um
we need to stop the old guys that
wear rush that wear shirts with russian
flags on them
because i think they're american
communists
it's been said it's been rumored and i
think
stop pollution yeah sure but
yeah sure yeah sure global warming
global warming and
like like wow i'm just being serious and
we're probably just being
like crazy but look i'm trying global
warming is nice when you're at the beach
when it's nice and hot
let's be honest but but and
in our in our reality global warming
isn't good right i agree with you
except when you're at the beach except
that but like
so here's the question is do you think
enough people are willing to give up
going to the beach and having a nice
time no
in order for the world not to global
warm no
right yeah but like but most of the
people that go to the beach are like
adults and kids and most of the kids no
what else would go
a parrot no an attack helicopter here
we we brought our dogs driving who's
driving the helicopter the attack
helicopter the whole
point of it being in an attack
helicopter is because it drives itself
and crashes into everything and blows
stuff up but it's a more it's an
immortal helicopter
you guys are legends now i want to ask
you you're a legend
thank you and i want to ask you guys too
you guys are
you know what age do you feel like you
might want to settle down kind of i know
you guys
settle down you mean like let myself go
yeah
oh what does that mean getting older i
know right now you guys try to take care
of your diet take care of your body
37. i have a diet so 37 you're thinking
of
starting to just let it go huh yeah just
like james harden
21 yeah he went to the party
and then he came back fat i think he had
a lot of doughnuts
he might have do you guys have any
suggestions for me yes
okay tear those curtain downs
break the window replace the windows
with wall
with walls and paint all the simpson
care simpsons characters
on the wall because you had that in your
studio in l.a remember
oh yeah yeah would it be a bad idea
we've thought about doing something
different we're working with this church
curtain vibration i need something
i have no idea what it is so you said
you saw the first season of stranger
things right
yeah what was your favorite part my
favorite part
was i didn't watch uh i like that little
kid with the um
glasses on excuse me
i like the little kid with the glasses
on who
the glasses
what what
oh
i don't i don't remember are you okay
what did it look like
did you have curly hair i don't remember
oh um
did anyone even wear glasses in the
first season what are you guys
okay wait what are you doing what are
you is it was it barb
who's barb yeah let's go to the barb
yeah it wasn't barb dude what are the
demogorgons do on friday night
they go to the barb wouldn't we like to
know
because they took her in the show my
favorite part everybody knows that
if anybody if anybody is watching this
that hasn't seen stranger things there's
spoilers my favorite part is when is
that
when the point they're they're
is there like why is it on your face oh
yeah what that
when they're um like when they're on the
bike chase with the big vans and then
l flips over the van with their mind
okay
okay okay okay okay
do you need a nap sir how do you guys
okay
we have a we have a
a we i o u
what
here do this max
are you thinking about getting plastic
surgery in the future
and like if i want to get plastic
surgery to look like my dog
you should get a nose job yeah
get a nose job i want to shave your
eyebrows and put eyebrow makeup on i
wanna get my eyes sewn closed
and write party time on each one i wanna
get my lip or my arm tattooed
saying i'm a goofy goober
have you not seen spongebob no yeah you
don't
you guys what did you do as a kid if you
didn't watch spongebob i don't watch
spongebob we rode our bike
cool we made ramps cool we hurt
ourselves
cool and the one you just said was the
fun part
people would vomit sometimes oh
pretty lit we used to eat ants i got
really sick
like a week ago and i grew up 12 times
and i stayed in a chair have you ever
had a feeling of being like
way down with like poop poop
do you even believe yourselves
i mean to i mean do you even believe in
me
look guys i there's this guy that was
born with the voice of
the voice of morgan freeman he
reincarnated as a lawnmower and the only
thing he can't do is open foil paper
nice nice do you want to hear my morgan
freeman impersonation
yes
what is wrong with you i didn't start it
yet here's my morgan premium
impersonation all right
okay they said it would take a minute
600 years to get out of this here prison
but andy dufresne did it in less than
20.
why are you like why did i even
get get us on that topic what's
something you just want to tell the
people out there you know let's go
to you guys about 30 seconds to just
tell people
what you want to say and then we can um
i want to say
that uh i am glad
to that i'm on this podcast because
i never thought i would be on a podcast
and that's all okay okay um
what i want to say is i feel very glad
to be on this podcast
and um just a thanks to my parents for
taking me out here and stuff
and um i actually want to promote ceo's
merch
by doing like a little sequence okay
okay
so i have his coding
yeah whatever website he has go buy
it please okay all right man well
bye you know i love you guys and i'm
glad you guys were able to be here today
and um we just say at the end of the
episode
we say we'll probably go out with a
little bit of eddie nine volt again
uh to come up excuse me and it's the
same song that we came in with
what's that supposed to mean and i want
to thank everybody for being a part of
the show you can get tickets at
theovonn.com
tour t-o-u-r
you're what don't buy through any other
site because uh
it's a scam it's a scam website that's
how i watch icarly
there you go a lot of scams out there do
governments create clouds for you to
stop seeing the end of the earth now
that's a question for this guy eddie
bravo a friend of mine who's not here
today
but i'm gonna ask him you guys be good
to yourselves man gang
um gang gang
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one